for Union day with our Charlie's Angels
what's the guy's name
Charlie
you're invited to the three-part real
house rides of Miami reunion cheers guys
that was strong
[Music]
who here do you think has the most sex
I've always had sex like four times a
night four times a night your poor
vagina Jacqueline from New York City
said Marcus is closer in age to your son
Scotty Junior than to you we wear the
size 15 shoes I think he's okay oh
Martina's diagnosis has radically
changed we are fighting two cancers like
one was not enough
heard Lenny he's been a cheater for a
long time like I know models that he
cheat with a lot of people commented the
girls all have a real Sisterhood
you haven't given me a story you haven't
given me a thank you you know what
what straight me just like you castrated
Russell
who is this from read the letter dear
Adriana I'm writing to tell you I'm
being abused the culprit of this abuse
is Marisol and he said I'm a star I'm a
star do you believe that you wouldn't
have not let Lenny do all the things
he's done to you what yes why would you
try to take me down I never wanted
anything to do with your ex-boyfriend I
regret it says that have no feelings and
you don't even apologize I don't
apologize to the devil show of hands
does Larsa hit below the belt
to put them on girl
okay
they're all talking at the same time
exhausted
[Music]